hello Internet welcome to film Theory
the show that wishes there was a night
map Pat to split the workload no more
so Rick and Morty is about to return
from its mid-season break but before it
does I figured it was a good time to
take a look at the season's first six
episodes to check out where things might
be headed next after ending season five
by blowing a huge hole into the universe
Rick and Morty open to season six with
an all-new all different mandate in our
previous Rick and Morty Theory we looked
specifically at the first episode of the
season to conclude that it was all about
ways of handling grief Rick refuses to
let go of his past trauma enough so that
he's torturing himself and everyone
around him with it you always do
everything you set your mind to except
keep your family alive but that was
hardly your fault meanwhile the Jerry
from season one's Cronenberg Universe
completely lets go of his past trauma to
a self-destructive degree refusing to
accept anyone into his life and severing
all ties with anyone from his past your
mom and sister died Morty and I moved on
from caring and that is the best deal
you will ever get the true solution
however is found somewhere in the middle
grief isn't solved by never moving on
but it's also not so solved by
completely moving on it's a process of
slow healing acknowledging that that
trauma is always going to be a part of
you and just learning to live with that
we concluded that this episode was
setting up a season-long theme of
healing for Rick working on himself and
boy howdy did we get that one right on
the money I haven't been more right
about a theory since uh in each of these
first six episodes we watch Rick
actively going out of his way to do the
most unrick thing ever helping the
family members around him when Beth
falls in love with a clone of herself in
episode 3 we see him doing something
we've never seen him do before in the
infinite universes give fatherly advice
I met myself out there infinite times
infinite happens including as you put it
for getting the ice cream you've
forgotten the ice cream don't worry
about what's crazy the kids say you do
you thank you so much Dad when Morty's
psyche is fragmented into a billion
Pieces by a video game Rick spends a
lifetime trying to put those pieces back
together lowering his emotional walls to
try and help recover as much of Morty as
he can I thought you would have left by
now was hoping to get at least half of
you home you really are a good grandson
you know that I'm proud of you Morty
Rick even decides to show Jerry some
respect Jerry knew I was right not even
close I just didn't want to see someone
get bullied maybe the single dumbest
human I've ever met Jerry but you still
have a right to take whatever you want
seriously and what a fortune cookie
Dooms Jerry to a fate worse than death
Rick even gives up Universal Power just
to save him you saved me I will never
stop holding this over you and while he
may have lost Immortal power he gained a
friend thanks friend friend did you just
say friend
I'm sorry I did that it's fine all of
this without the crutch of
interdimensional portal travel despite
Rick saying that he was working on
fixing it throughout the season have a
process but of course nothing can last
forever in the final episode right
before the mid-season break Rick
restores portal travel and Promises to
return to Classic wacky Rick and Morty
Adventures I did it I fixed portal
travel it's gonna be classic episode 40
Adventures Morty social commentary rude
characters here we go Rick and Morty
time so now this begs the question with
Rick and the Smiths well on their way
through the healing process what comes
next are we leaving behind the Canon and
lore established by the front half of
the season and returning to completely
disconnected episodic Adventures like
Rick says I don't think so and it's all
because of one simple truth healing
leaves scars physically emotionally and
mentally and it's time our characters
start dealing with those scars and of
them none is bigger than a certain
interdimensional world Hopper set up in
The Season's very first episode why are
you here buddy I have been asking myself
that exact same question that's right
Friends by analyzing the seasons episode
so far and what they're saying about the
show's characters I believe that we can
predict exactly where Rick and Morty is
headed for the rest of the season and
well yeah we're gonna see The Return of
some Dimension hopping Adventures across
space and time we're also gonna be
pulling on a story thread that's been
lingering over our heads for several
seasons Now spoiler alert there's a rick
out there that's gonna shatter the
status quo of this universe forever so
open up your emergency fortune cookie
loyal theorists we're heading in now
obviously Rick healing the bonds with
his family was a huge part of these
first six episodes but that wasn't all
another recurring theme that stood out
across the first half of the season was
dissatisfaction everyone who got what
they thought they wanted actually didn't
end up all that happy about it Marta the
leader of the Morty religion inside
Morty's brain manages to unite 92 of the
world to her cause a Monumental task but
she's left unhappy with the reality that
not everyone in this video game
simulation is going to be United as one
the nocturnal Smith Knight family
manages to overthrow the day smiths in a
coup thereby allowing him to be in
charge of their lives but then they hate
the responsibility that comes with being
active during the day so they
voluntarily hand control back to the day
Smiths when hyper-intelligent space
Dinosaurs show up on Earth to create a
Utopia for Humanity humans just become
bored with this life without struggle I
can't live like this anymore at first it
was fun spending all day watching
whatever YouTube Auto plays after the
last one Auto plays but a man can only
watch so many ads for grammarly help us
go back to the old days where we pretend
to fix the problems we call in every
case these characters are getting
exactly what they wanted but they're
left empty by it in some way or another
so what does it mean if you're left
unfulfilled after getting what you want
what even is the purpose of life is
there a purpose to life well that my
friends brings us to a personal favorite
of the Rick and Morty franchise nihilism
the belief that nothing matters now this
is really just boiling it down to the
Bare Bones but nihilists often believe
that there's no moral order no actual
fund mental purpose to life or existence
within the universe again nothing
matters and it's this concept that
almost perfectly embodies Rick Sanchez a
man who has seen infinity and has thus
lost the ability to care about finite
things nothing matters because all the
outcomes are not only possible they've
already happened out there somewhere
he's seen how pointless it is to try and
solve a problem I could take you right
now to the same Battlefield in a
universe where we lost or another where
the war never even happened all equally
real all equally unreal none of it
matters then why did you help so you
could say that these characters getting
what they want and then find out it
didn't mean anything supports the view
of nihilism it proves that Rick Sanchez
is right but there are other ways to
look at this philosophy there's a flip
side here that views a pointless
Universe positively it's called
optimistic nihilism if we truly live in
a universe where nothing matters well
that's just another way of saying that
everything matters equally anything can
matter as much as you decide it matters
you could for instance decide that this
channel matters more to you than
anything else in the universe and then
go and hit that subscribe button below
the video under optimistic nihilism that
is a perfectly Fair assessment and
looking at the general ecosystem of
YouTube yeah I'd say it's not that far
off in the context of Rick and Morty of
all characters in the show Morty's the
one who most closely represents this
belief he laid this all out way back in
season one nobody exists on purpose
nobody belongs anywhere everybody's
gonna die come watch TV Rick's healing
Arc through the first half of the season
has shown him slowly coming over to this
exact idea he knows that scientifically
nothing matters because he's seen the
infinite Multiverse with the people and
events in his small corner of that
Multiverse can matter when Jerry gives
Rick a friendship fortune cookie sure
Rick calls this out as a stupid gesture
but notice that he keeps the fortune he
even goes so far as to look at it again
before putting it in his pocket it's a
small gesture that meant something with
Beth constantly going through
self-confidence issues Rick decides to
leave out a special wine that helps her
open up and discover herself with space
Beth and when a portion of Morty's asks
that Rick keep their Video Game World on
so they can continue to exist Rick
listens and chooses to follow that
request what's with the jacked up Roy
machine shouldn't you be taking that to
repairs yeah special order some rich
wants his last game to keep running
hooked it up to an external battery
we're just supposed to start he has no
reason to do this he got exactly what he
wanted out of the game and has nothing
to gain from being beholden to a video
game character and yet he keeps the game
running because it's a nice thing to do
it's a small action that has a big
impact in the personal Universe of
someone else it's what all of these
situations in season six have in common
he has nothing to gain but he's using
his Godlike powers to actually help his
family even back in episode 1 Rick
chooses to rescue The Smiths instead of
continuing his self-destructive pursuit
of Rick Prime could have left you guys
you think the concept of Family Matters
to me I'm not even your Rick this
positive attitude is starting to leak
into other parts of the show as well
throughout the last five seasons Rick
has gotten actively annoyed whenever the
show gets meta calling a 10 attention to
its own narrative in order to play with
the concept of how narrative works
that's what the whole story Train
episode was about a satire on story
structure and the in-universe
consequences of long-form Storytelling
he even has contempt for his own
backstory you want to jump the shark
you're gonna know my stupid crybaby
backstory knock yourself out and really
Rick's previous hatred for the idea of
continuity is just an extension of his
nihilism if you believe that nothing
matters well Canon and lore directly
conflict with that belief but now after
healing and embracing this more
optimistic view of the world Rick
suddenly cares about the potential
stories that his series can explore for
example when he's asked about the rift
left by last season's finale he actively
defends its existence if you'd like we
could patch up your little
interdimensional Rift too no leave it I
know how to close that it's there for a
reason very canonical normally that's
the sort of thing that would drive him
insane he despised the fact that it's
there and yet when the space dinosaurs
sew the rift shut Rick becomes Furious
about the apparent loss of potential
stories and it was all canonical and we
could have milked that thing for whole
season or like a three episode Arc at
least continuity is slowly starting to
matter to him because it anchors him it
grounds him it gives him something to
actually care about sure in the grand
scheme it might be meaningless but him
it does have meaning but this sort of
investment from characters as powerful
as Rick can have some major consequences
in episode 6 we meet the space dinosaurs
super intelligent beings on par with
Rick these dinosaurs travel the universe
to help other species while doing sick
Ollies it's on Iguanodon
[Music]
but wherever the dinosaurs go to help
meteors follow apparently a species of
giant meteor evolved to be their equal
opposite their ideological Nemesis as
these reptiles evolve to higher and
higher levels of loving vegan godhood
another life form devolved into an
equally selfless hate-filled species of
barely sentient rocks they hurdle
through space and do as much damage as
they can to their chosen enemy which is
guess who it's a force of absolute death
and destruction versus an equal and
opposite force of creation and
creativity the more good the dinosaurs
do and the more successful they are the
more meteors are born to destroy their
progress and here's the thing if this is
indeed a rule of the universe enough so
that it's happened several times to the
dinosaurs this then also applies to Rick
after all he and the space dinos already
see themselves as equals from one God
being to another you're welcome so it
would follow that Rick also has himself
an equal and opposite force a force
that's been evolving alongside Rick in
the opposite direction oh oh you found
me
and shoot the first monitor too that's
right loyal theorists I believe that
Rick Prime the character that killed our
Rick's family and started the entire
chain of events that would lead to this
series is not only are Rick's Nemesis
but his Universal counterweight kind of
it's actually more accurate to say that
our wreck is Rick primes meteor see from
what we can tell Rick Prime is basically
the richest Rick in all existence and
seems to be the embodiment of that
pessimistic view of nihilism that our
Rick used to follow out of what little
we've seen of him Rick Prime genuinely
doesn't seem to care about anything
beyond spreading the good word of not
caring about anything to his fellow
Ricks Ricks don't pass on this he
doesn't even seem to care about his
family at all Morty for you to be bait
the guide have to Value something he
truly does not give basically Rick Prime
is like the Rick that we knew from
previous Seasons but amped up to 11.
without any of the character development
growth and healing that we've seen our
Rick going through he's the sort of guy
that would hop to a new universe in a
heartbeat leaving all his loved ones
behind the second things get dicey so
just like the space dinosaurs floated
through the Universe helping out anyone
they could Rick Prime goes from
University Universe making things worse
through the creation of other
pessimistic nihilistic Ricks but in that
process he literally created our Rick he
killed his wife and daughter which sets
off the events of the series including
the healing and character growth that
we're watching our Rick go through right
now and through this process our Rick
has taken his first steps to being Rick
Prime's equal opposite a Rick that
genuinely cares you know the status quo
of this franchise the irreverent
Adventures where nothing of any
consequence happens that is a thing of
the past represented in a lot of ways by
Rick Prime just think we finally know
what happened to our Rick's family when
it happened on the timeline where it
happened in the Multiverse how it went
down and who did it but we're still
missing that one key piece of data why
why did Rick Prime do this in the first
place explicitly all we get is a vague
offhanded explanation that Ricks don't
typically refuse the Call to multiversal
Adventure but we don't know why it's so
important to Rick Prime that other Ricks
follow in his footsteps maybe this is
why maybe he understands that an equally
powerful but oppositely aligned Rick
would one day rise up to stop him and he
wanted to make sure that that didn't
happen or maybe fate is just pulling him
to create his equal opposite Rick I for
one can't wait to find out but hey we
interrupt your regularly scheduled
programming to bring you your daily
allotment of capitalism that's right
loyal theorists the holiday season is
quickly approaching and you know that
means we got ourselves some new Theory
wear that makes the perfect gift for you
or the theorist in your life this time
around if you don't feel like wearing
any game theory green we've got
ourselves some film Theory merch to help
you rep the red first off we got this
great film Theory Academy hoodie for
anyone who wants to embrace their inner
film student it's a really cool design
and we kept it a little bit oversized so
you can be cozy inside of those chilly
movie theaters as you get ready to watch
insert Disney tent pool here this
holiday plus we also have ourselves an
awesome screen themed vintage ringer
t-shirt which would look amazing layered
under that Academy hoodie it's almost
like we planned this stuff out oh and uh
this one's a bit wild but do you love
vintage analog horror but you just wish
you could give the tapes a big old fuzzy
hug well now you can with our film
Theory VHS plushie it even comes with a
cool little zippered case to keep it
safe just one warning don't feed it
after midnight and if you've ever
wondered what this channel smells like
you can find out with our new candle set
at the very least you can help them
summon the next season of Rick and Morty
that much faster so grab a gift that'll
make the theorist in your life happy or
just treat yourself to a little
something special this holiday you
deserve a nice gift too links to all the
items are below this video or you can
just go to theoryware.com to check out
the full collection I think there are
some special discounts and bundles over
on the merch site so you might want to
check those out and in the meantime
remember it's all just a theory a film
Theory and cut